entonces donde lo dejamos estaba
tratando de darles la intuición de lo
que es la divergencia y luego que se me
acabe el tiempo pero de todos modos
había definido este campo vectorial que
es muy sencillo que nos dice que la
velocidad de las partículas de un fluido
permíteme déjenme limpiarlo porque está
todo tachonado verdad la velocidad la
voy a escribir como un medio de x en la
dirección del eje del eje x verdad en la
dirección horizontal entonces no hay
ningún movimiento hacia arriba en el
plano xy cuando lo estaba dibujando
decía bueno cuando x es igual a 1
entonces la magnitud de este vector
velocidad es un medio cuando x vale 2
entonces va hacia la derecha con una
magnitud de 1 y etcétera no mientras más
nos vayamos alejando en él hacia la
derecha entonces las partículas se
mueven más rápido hacia la derecha muy
bien ahora vamos a tratar de ver qué es
lo que significa la divergencia en
primer lugar vamos a considerar la
divergencia de esta función así que la
divergencia de nuestro campo vectorial
ok de nuestro campo de velocidad
pues simplemente podremos escribirlo
como el gradiente punto nuestro campo
vectorial verdad que es el triangulito
volteado y que nos dice que hay que
derivar la primera componente respecto
de equis y sumar la derivada de la
segunda componente respecto de ella en
este caso la derivada de la primer
componente es un medio de x verdad que
al derivar lo tenemos que es un medio y
no hay una segunda componente así que
así se queda la divergencia en cualquier
punto es un medio ahora que nos dice eso
bueno si miras la definición entonces
dijimos que sólo nos tomó o mejor dicho
cuanto se incrementa en la dirección x
lo vamos a ver visualmente a medida que
avanzamos en la dirección x el campo se
hace más y más fuerte ya que sabemos que
es la velocidad de unas partículas yendo
en la dirección x pues significa que
irán más rápido hacia la derecha lo que
nos está diciendo es que si fuéramos a
tomar por ejemplo un círculo arbitrará
arbitrariamente pequeño
creo que vamos a tener que dibujar lo
voy a dibujar lo de otro color digamos
un círculo arbitrariamente pequeño
haciendo lo suficientemente grande para
que se entienda lo que quiero decir que
es lo que está pasando bueno a medida
que nos vamos acercando al lado derecho
tengo partículas saliendo muy muy rápido
de este círculo verdad entonces digamos
que en un cierto tiempo en un cierto
tiempo digamos segundo en un segundo las
partículas se mueven muy rápido y voy a
tener un montón de partículas que se
alejan del lado derecho y en esa misma
cantidad de tiempo tengo por el lado
izquierdo que entran pero un menor
número de partículas así que la forma de
pensarlo es que en una cantidad de
tiempo porque es lo que pasa que en este
espacio tengo que entran pocas
partículas por la izquierda y un número
mucho mayor de ella se aleja por la
derecha entonces en ese espacio va a ser
menos denso verdad debido a que va a
haber menos partículas en cierto en
cierto momento ya que son más las que se
alejan que las que
eso es lo que nos dice esta divergencia
positiva en este en este circuito verdad
y como es un medio en todas partes en
cualquier punto de este campo vectorial
el campo se vuelve menos denso o se
podría decir que está fluyendo más hacia
afuera verdad tiene sentido hablar desde
esta de esta forma entonces sólo nos
quedaremos en este primer cuadrante para
estos ejemplos para para redondear las
ideas muy bien entonces en conclusión
las partículas son cada vez más y más
rápidas debido a que nuestra derivada
con respecto a x es positiva la
pendiente de nuestra primera componente
respecto de x aumenta es decir es
positiva así que a medida que avanzamos
hacia la derecha las velocidades van más
y más rápidas ok
siempre vamos a tener más saliendo por
la derecha no importa donde donde pinte
este este círculo verdad así que se va
volviendo menos denso ok un punto
determinado es entonces como una fuente
de partículas o si tenemos una
van a salir más de las que entran por la
izquierda así que podríamos ver esta
divergencia positiva como bueno que el
campo es cada vez menos denso en cada
punto o que el punto es una fuente del
campo es una una fuente de partículas es
dependiendo de cuál es el modelo que
desees utilizar verdad es cómo podemos
interpretarlo
ahora vamos a tomar la situación opuesta
por ejemplo déjenme borro para para que
quede más claro digamos ahora que el
campo vectorial es menos un medio de x
por el vector unitario en la dirección
horizontal y así la divergencia voy voy
a usar esta anotación con el triangulito
al revés en realidad esto es una
derivada parcial respecto de x que es
menos un medio si tuviera que
representar la y este es mi eje y y este
es mi eje x muy bien entonces si voy a
representar esto hoy déjenme pongo bien
la flechita de aquí mismo en él
1 mi velocidad va a ser un medio pero en
este caso va a ser a la izquierda en el
punto 2 mi velocidad va a ser hacia la
izquierda un metro por segundo digamos
si estamos manejando eso en la velocidad
3 será 3 medios y bueno creo que la idea
ya ya ya sabes no que no depende de yes
sólo depende de x como vimos en el
ejemplo anterior así que ahora vamos a
dibujar un pequeño círculo y vamos a ver
qué es lo que está pasando dibujemos lo
por ejemplo aquí esto es infinitamente
pequeño pero bueno es para que quede
claro la idea como en el ejemplo
anterior entonces tengo unas pocas
partículas saliendo por el lado
izquierdo verdad pero tengo muchas más
partículas entrando en esta región que
he definido por el círculo
estoy teniendo muchas partículas que
entran por la derecha así que en
cualquier periodo de tiempo en mi
espacio definido que es este círculo se
va a volver más y más denso conforme
pasa el tiempo correcto así que cada vez
es más densa o podrías verlo como que
como que este espacio está absorbiendo
partículas
es como un pozo de partícula de
partículas en el ejemplo anterior las
partículas salían ahora entran más por
la derecha de las que salen por la
izquierda y justo eso es una divergencia
negativa casi se podría decir vamos a
pensar en la palabra divergencia cuando
es positiva tengo una divergencia
positiva de partículas o que estan
divergiendo desde de ese punto si tengo
una divergencia negativa pues a lo mejor
deberíamos llamarlo convergencia verdad
converger es lo opuesto a divergir así
que aquí a pesar de que algunas
partículas están saliendo las de la
izquierda muchas más partículas entran
por la derecha por lo que se está
haciendo más y más denso este es un
ejemplo y de hecho en todos los puntos
sucede que hay una divergencia negativa
verdad así que todo este campo se está
volviendo más denso y el ejemplo clásico
de una divergencia para un área
determinada por ejemplo es el ejemplo
clásico que se ve algo como esto
digamos estos son mis ejes
déjenme pintarlos bien con su flechita
entonces si tenemos un campo que se ve
como como de este estilo es el ejemplo
clásico de una divergencia negativa
correcto donde desde todas las
direcciones hay partículas que le van
entrando a esta región así que
obviamente en cualquier periodo de
tiempo esta región es cada vez más densa
y el ejemplo clásico de una divergencia
positiva pues es un punto en donde donde
se las flechas van al revés verdad en
todas las direcciones están sal y están
saliendo de esta región delimitada por
un círculo así que estamos hablando de
velocidad de partículas después de un
momento en donde más partículas están
yéndose que entrando no hay partículas
que estén ingresando ahora qué significa
si tenemos una divergencia cero
qué significará que tengamos una
divergencia a 0 así que vamos a hacer un
campo vectorial que tenga una
divergencia 0 digamos que nuestro campo
b vamos a mantenernos en una dimensión
para para dejar esto claro digamos que
nuestro campo es 5 veces y ok donde ya
sabemos que es el vector unitario en la
dirección horizontal
entonces pintemos nuestros ejes
nuevamente este campo vectorial siempre
va a ser 5 y
es un campo vectorial constante verdad
así que la magnitud de los vectores no
importa qué valor de x tome siempre va a
ser la misma y siempre va hacia la
derecha verdad entonces tenemos una
colección de flechitas así
no depende esto de de y de hecho tampoco
de equis pero bueno lo importante es que
todas las flechitas tienen la misma
magnitud
así que si dibujamos una región que pasa
aquí bueno hay más partículas que entran
hay más que se van pues en realidad no
para cualquier cantidad la misma
cantidad de partículas salen que la que
entra así que cuando tenemos una
divergencia cero lo que pasa en el campo
es que no se convierte en mi más densa
ni menos densa entonces déjenme déjenme
hacer otro por ejemplo si mi función era
2 y más 2 j por ejemplo sigue siendo
constante correcto este campo de
velocidad o de vectores se ve algo así
donde todos los vectores del campo
apuntan en la misma dirección de hecho
tienen pendiente uno pero
pues realmente sigue siendo constante en
el siguiente vídeo vamos a ver un
ejemplo todavía más padre con lo
importante es que la misma cantidad de
partículas que entran son las que salen
y esto tiene sentido porque la
divergencia de este campo vectorial pues
en realidad tiene una divergencia
digamos la de la derivada parcial de
12-0 y la derivada parcial de 2 respecto
de iu es 0 también entonces su
divergencia es cero otra vez se me acaba
el tiempo así que nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo